revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 mañana de lunes empezamos una
nueva semana informativa Marta Moya
Gracias por estar como siempre con
nosotros repasando toda la prensa
internacional vamos a empezar con un
gran tema del día de nuestra agenda
internacional también no solo el día
sino de este fin de semana que acaba de
pasarlas inusuales protestas en China
que han generado todo tipo de reacciones
a lo largo del mundo pero también vamos
a los medios o chinos donde la noticia
ha pasado desapercibida no Marta y Raúl
buenos días vamos a empezar con un
artículo del Guardian que registra un
poco todo esto no como los medios han
cubierto y no han cubierto las protestas
generalizadas contra el covid 0 en China
sostiene este artículo del Guardian que
los medios estatales han ignorado en
gran medida las protestas mientras que
si han defendido esas medidas
restrictivas del cómic 0 impulsadas por
el gobierno de chillimping destaca este
artículo que ni en la prensa escrita ni
en la televisión se ha reportado este
hecho no destaca concretamente que la
cctv que es esta cadena Estatal ha
pasado la mañana del lunes cubriendo el
anuncio del lanzamiento de una nave
espacial del 15 que se va a dar Este
martes pero que no ha habido ni rastro
de las protestas los esfuerzos para
contener el virus sí que se han mostrado
tanto en portadas como en análisis y en
diferentes editoriales de la prensa
china algunos medios Eso sí han hablado
de afinar la estrategia que algunos
analistas consideran que podría ser algo
así como un guiño a las protestas sin
embargo los medios más alineados con el
partido comunista chino han destacado en
editoriales que tienen que adherirse de
manera inquebrantable a las políticas
como el único camino para hacer frente a
la pandemia destacamos también el global
Times que es este periódico también muy
alineado con el partido comunista que en
su portada pues no da grandes muestras
de reportar estas protestas destaca
investigación chino que ha llegado a
Nueva Zelanda también titula sobre las
elecciones locales en Taiwán y en la
columna de la derecha Así que dice que
se insta a una mayor precisión de la
estrategia del covid el Shanghai Daily
también destaca por ejemplo la
reapertura de un centro comercial pero
ni rastro de las protestas Así es sin
embargo Marta hay un medio chino que ha
cuestionado especialmente las políticas
del confinamiento del gobierno chino de
quién vamos a hablar pues si Raúl
hablamos del South china Moreno que es
este periódico de Hong Kong que tampoco
se refiere explícitamente a las
protestas pero sí que dice que mientras
china alcanza el récord de contagios
puede continuar esta estrategia de Kobe
0 destaca y analiza con expertos
epidemiólogos que el aumento de casos
con estas medidas restrictivas no van a
ser sostenibles si continúan estas
protestas por la
política del covid cero no sostiene este
artículo del sauchain amor en Pos que
hay que parar con las pruebas masivas
que hay que los recursos en los casos
más graves de covid 19 y que sobre todo
hay que aumentar las tasas de vacunación
entre las personas más vulnerables
además también refleja la parte del
gobierno que dice que el cero es la
única vía porque el sistema de salud
chino no puede vivir con el virus porque
la propagación descontrolada de la
pandemia daría lugar a una explosión de
casos y de muertes bueno Al contrario de
la prensa china Marta en los medios
internacionales hay casi unanimidad en
El retrato de las aportadas de las
protestas en las portadas Mejor dicho
empezamos con Francia Liberación Sí
vamos porque todas casi todas la prensa
internacional refleja esto empezamos
nosotros incluso nosotros empezamos en
Francia como decías y en Liberación
titula contundentemente un cólera
contagioso se ve la imagen de uno de las
miles de personas que ha salido a las
calles en este último fin de semana y
sostiene Liberación que las
manifestaciones contra y persistente
confinamiento de parte del gobierno de
en el marco de su política cobi 0
reaviva el deseo de la libertad de la
población
Marta el británico de Times titula la
mayor protesta en China desde tianamén
recordemos Diana 1989 tras casi siete
semanas de protestas de los estudiantes
pidiendo un cambio social amplio al
final del ejército chino decidió
reprimir esas protestas y sostiene que
es la muestra pública de desafección
contra el gobierno de silimpin más
importante desde entonces han pasado 30
años desde entonces y que los
estudiantes inundaron varios Campos
universitarios en Beijing en Shanghai
gritaron abajo el partido comunista
chino y pidieron también abiertamente la
destitución del presidente
muy rápidamente destacamos el titular
que dice protestas contra la política
del covid en varias ciudades chinas
también hay
titula un incendio mortal estimula los
disturbios en China por las políticas de
cobitzero nos referimos al incendio de
la semana pasada en la fábrica
Industrial en urunki que dejó
aproximadamente 10 muertos y esto
levantó las críticas porque las medidas
restrictivas de allí se supone que
impidieron agilizar esas tareas de
rescate y Esto fue el germen de las
protestas exactamente
en Argentina también titula con esta
cuestión que dice inédito desafío así en
las calles de China se ve también la
imagen de los manifestantes que gritaron
queremos libertad decenas de miles de
personas salieron a la calle para
protestar en el mayor desafío contra el
gobierno en década y lo que ocurre en
China Marta con esta ginetas protestas
no solo acapara las portadas sino
también artículos de análisis vamos con
Sky news titula el partido comunista
chino enfrenta una amenaza no vista
desde las protestas que llevaron a la
masacre de la plaza de Diana men estas
manifestaciones son trascendentales y
dice el sky news que donde quiera que
vayan ya son enormemente significativas
las protestas contra el cero vienen
desde hace meses pero solo Ahora se han
registrado o han adquirido un garista
transversal por la ira acumulada y el
resentimiento sostiene este análisis de
skyrius que el gobierno chino y la
sociedad firmaron una especie de
contrato hace años que decía así los
haremos prósperos y mantendremos la
sociedad estable y ustedes nos
permitirán seguir dirigiendo el país
parece que este pacto de la estabilidad
y la prosperidad ahora mismo está un
poco endeble porque los chinos ven como
el resto del mundo se abre y se
desprende un poco de la pandemia Ven a
miles de aficionados en Qatar sin
mascarilla y ellos siguen encerrados y
que por tanto es posible que los
disturbios continúen y es el mayor
desafío que no es el Coby perse sino es
la gente en la calle para el gobierno
Qué dice para finalizar Marta finals
que enfrenta el desafío más difícil para
gobernar que sillín tienes el líder más
poderoso desde Mao zedong porque aseguró
su tercer mandato hace pocas fechas al
mando de partido comunista chino y que
ahora una de esas políticas que ha
impulsado es la de cito textualmente la
expansión de su draconiano aparato de
seguridad de vigilancia del estado y la
rápida represión de las señales de
disidencia y ahora tiene que moverse
entre fines finos equilibrios entre esa
represión y la libertad de los chinos
que salen a protestar no solo portadas
tampoco análisis vamos rápidamente con
unas viñetas y ya sí la despidió Marta
sí vamos con el de Elite Telegram la
piñata de blower que vemos aquí al
estilo Mao no con su doctrina en la mano
Desde esa Atalaya con sus drones viendo
como la policía reprime y arresta a los
manifestantes que están protestando
contra el cero destacamos también la
viñeta Times del norte morland Cuando
vemos a Shin Pink con este traje de
protección personal que hemos visto no
durante la pandemia enfrentándose a un
dragón que ya le ha quemado parte del
cuerpo que es un poco símbolo de las
protestas y también símbolo de esa
germen de las protestas que fue el
incendio Y por último destacarnos el
Cartoon una viñeta del australiav que
vemos a ese oso panda que es un símbolo
claro de la sociedad china que se ha
quitado la mascarilla y en esa boca
abierta simboliza esa cárcel donde están
estas personas que están protestando
analizamos todo ese tema con nuestro
primer invitado del día Marta Muchísimas
gracias Mañana más revista